the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so for the last two lectures we've been
talking about analyzing algorithms
complexity orders of growth how do we
estimate the cost of an algorithm as the
size of the input grows and as I've said
several times I'll say at least once
more how do we also turn at the other
direction how do we use thoughts about
choices of pieces of algorithm in terms
of implications on the cost it's going
to take us to compute we saw last time a
set of examples constant algorithms
linear algorithms
sorry constant algorithms logarithmic
algorithms linear algorithms quadratic
algorithms exponential algorithms today
what I'm going to do is fill in one more
piece a log linear algorithm something
that's really a nice kind of algorithm
to have and use it to talk about one
last class of algorithms that are really
valuable and those are searching and
sorting algorithms so a search algorithm
kind of an obvious statement you use
them all the time when you go to Google
or Bing or whatever your favorite search
mechanism on the web is it's just a way
to find an item or a group of items from
a collection if you think about it that
collection could be either implicit or
explicit so way back at the beginning of
the term we saw an example of a search
algorithm when you were looking for
square roots and we saw simple things
like a new or exhaustive enumeration
we'd go through all the possibilities we
saw our first version of bisection
search there where you would do
approximations newton raphson these are
all examples of a search algorithm where
the collection is implicit it's all the
numbers between some point at some other
point more comment is a search algorithm
where the collection is explicit I don't
know for example I've got all the data
records of students and I want to know
how do I find a particular student so I
can record that a plus that everybody in
this room is going to get next Tuesday
on that exam that's not a promise sorry
but we'll work on it
so could do it in place it could do it
explicit doing search explicitly and it
could be on different kinds of
collections but I'm going to focus just
as an example on search over lists and
to
make it a little easier let's just do
search over lists of numbers but it
could obviously the other kinds of
elements now you've already seen some of
this right we did search where we said
we could do linear search brute force
just walk down the list looking at
everything until we either find the
thing we're looking for or we get to the
end of the list sometimes also called
British Museum algorithm or exhaustive
enumeration I go through everything in
the list nice news is the list doesn't
have to be sorted it could be just an
arbitrary order what we saw is that the
expected sorry not expected the worst
case behavior is linear in the worst
case the elements not in the list I got
a look at everything so it's going to be
linear in terms of complexity and then
we looked at bisection search where we
said the list needs to be sorted but if
it is we can actually be much more
efficient because we can take advantage
of the sorting to cut down the size of
the problem and I'll remind you about
both of those there was our simple
little linear search right set a flag
that says I haven't yet found it and
then just loop over the indices into the
list I could have also just looped
directly over the list itself checking
to see if the ithe member of the list is
the thing I'm looking for if it is
changed the flag to true so that when I
come out of all of this I'll return the
flag either false because it was set
that way initially or true because I
found it and of course what we knew is
we have to look at everything to see if
it's there or not I could speed this up
by just returning true at this point
well that would improve the average case
doesn't improve the worst case and
that's the thing we usually are
concerned about because in the worst
case I got to go through everything and
just to remind you we said this is order
length of the list to go around this
part the loop right here and inside the
loop it's constant work I'm doing the
same number of things each time that's
order n times order 1 and Beyer rules
that's just order M so it's linear in
the size of the problem ok we said we
could do it on sorted lists but just
again walk down the list again here I
could loop over everything in the list
checking to see if it's the thing I want
returned true and if I ever get to a
point where the element of the list is
big
than the thing I'm looking for I know it
can't be in the rest of the list because
all the things to the right are bigger
yet I could just return false and drop
out in terms of average behavior this is
better because it's going to stop as
soon as it gets to a point where it can
rule everything else out but in terms of
complexity it's still order am because
are still on average half - not average
in the worst case I'm still going to be
looking n times through the loop before
I get to a point where I can decide to
bail out of it so order an and then
finally last piece of recap bisection
search repeat again the idea here is
take the midpoint of the list look at
that element if it's the thing I'm
looking for great I just won the lottery
if it isn't decide is the thing I'm
looking for bigger or less than that
middle point if it's bigger than that I
only use the upper half of the list if
it's less than that I only use the lower
half of the list and the characteristic
here was at each step I'm reducing the
size of the problem in half I'm throwing
away half of the remaining list at each
step it'll just remind you of that code
I know it's a lot here but just to
remind you it said down here if I've got
an empty list can't be there I'm going
to return false otherwise call this
little helper function with the list the
thing for which I'm searching and the
beginning and end point indices into the
list initially start in the very end and
this code up here basically says if
those two numbers are the same I'm down
to a list of one just check to see if
it's the thing I'm looking for otherwise
pick something halfway in between and
ignore this case for the moment
basically then check to see is the thing
at that point bigger than II in which
case I'm in general going to call this
only with from the low point to the mid
point otherwise I'm going to call this
with the mid point too high and that was
just this idea of keep cutting down in
half the size of the list last piece of
the recap the thing we wanted you to see
here is there are the two recursive
calls I'm going to do only going to do
one because I'm making a decision at
each step I'm cutting down the problem
by half and that says the number of
steps the number of times I'm going to
iterate through here will be log in the
length of the list and if that still
doesn't make sense to you it says I need
to know when one over two to the K where
K is the number of steps is equal to one
because on each step I'm reducing by
half and that's when K is log base two
of n so that's why it's log linear and
so this just reminds you again that
recap number of calls reduce it outside
the call it gets reduced by factor two
each time I'm going to have log n work
going around it and inside its constant
amount of work because I'm just passing
the pointers not actually copying the
list and that's a nice state to be okay
so sounds good could just use linear
search it's going to be linear when you
use binary search or bisection search we
can do it in log time that's great we
assumed the list was sorted but all
right so that less basically says okay
so when does it make sense to sort the
list and then do the search right
because if I can sort the list cheaply
then the search is going to be
logarithmic that's really what I would
like this little expression basically
says let's let sort be the cost of
sorting the list I want to know when
that cost plus something that's order
log n which is what it's going to cost
me to do the search when is that less
than something that's order M because
then it's going to be better to do the
sort first and do the search and so I
can just rearrange it it needs to be
when does the cost of sorting when is it
less than this expression which
basically says when is sorting going to
be less expensive than the linear cost
crud actually good news for you right
this is a really short lecture because
it says it's never true ouch don't worry
if we got more to go in the lecture the
reason it can't be true if you think
about it just informally is if I've got
a collection of n elements and I want to
sort it I've got to look at each one of
those elements at least once right I
have to look at them to decide where
they go oh that's n
elements so the sorting must be at least
order n because I got to look at
everything and in fact as it says there
I'm going to have to use at least linear
time to do the sort sounds like we're
stuck but we're not and the reason is
often when I want to search something
I'm going to do multiple searches but I
may only want to sort the list once in
fact I probably only want to sort the
list once so in that case I'm spreading
out the cost i'm amortizing the expense
of the sort and now what I want to know
is if I'm going to do K searches the
cost of those K searches I know is going
to be K log n because it's log to do the
search and I simply need to know is the
cost of sorting plus this can I have
something where it's less than K search
is just using linear search and the
answer is yes there are going to be four
large k's ways in which we can do this
sort where the sort time becomes
irrelevant that the cost is really
dominated by the search and so what I
want to do now is look at all right how
could we do this sort reasonably
efficiently it's going to have to be at
least linear we're going to see it's
going to be a little more than linear
but if I could do it reasonably I'm
going to be in good shape here so what I
want to do is show you a number of ways
in which we can do sorting take a list
of elements and sort them from in this
case smaller to higher are in increasing
order so here's my goal I want to
efficiently sort a list I want to see if
we can do this as efficiently as
possible I'm going to start I'm going to
say with a humorous version of sort
you've all convinced that my humor is
non-existent you're right but it sets
the stage for this is I saw you can look
it up it's called monkey sort BOGO sort
stupid sort slow store permutation store
shotgun store and here's how it works
anna has nicely given me a set of
numbers on cards here here's how you do
BOGO sort now I got to do that better
I've got to spread them out randomly
look this oh good I'm going to have to
sorry Tom I'm now walking and now I pick
them up saying is that less than this
which is less than Oh crud they're not
sorted
all right I pick them all up and I do it
again a little brain damage right now
it's intended to get your attention I
did I heard a couple of chuckles those
are a students by the way I heard a
couple of chuckles here we could
actually do this exhaustively basically
it's called permutation sort because you
could search through all possible
permutations to see if you find
something that's sorted that by the way
the complexity of that is something like
n factorial which for large n is n to
the nth power and that fends anything
bigger than about two don't do it all
right but it would be a way to think
about doing this all right now having
caught in the humorous version of this
how could we do this a little bit better
sorry I should say what's the complexity
there's a nice crisp definition of bogo
sort it's best-case is order n because I
just need to check it sorted it's
average case is n factorial and it's
worst case if I'm just doing it randomly
as God knows because I could be doing it
here forever so we're going to move on
here's the second way to do it call
bubble sort I'm going to do this with a
small version of this I'm going to put
out a settle it turn these up so you can
see them in a second the idea of bubble
sort is I'm going to start up I'm going
to call this the front end of the list
and I'm going to walk down comparing
elements one it pairwise and I'm always
going to move the larger one over so I
start here and I say ones less than 11
I'm okay
11 is bigger than 5 I'm going to bubble
that up 11 is bigger than 6 I'm going to
bubble that up 11 is bigger than 2 I've
basically bubbled 11 to the end now I go
back here I say 1 is less than 5 that's
good 5 is less than 6 that's good
6 is bigger than 2 bubble that 6 is less
than 11 you get the idea comparison
comparison and swapped comparison
comparison and now if I go back to this
part and do it you'll notice that's in
the right order that's in the right
order that's in the right order that's
in the right order I'm done
small round of applause please I was
able to sort five elements thank you the
little video is sort of showing in the
same thing you can see the idea here
it's called bubble sort because you're
literally bubbling things up out to the
end of the list it's pretty simple to do
you're just swapping pairs and as you
saw when I get to the end of the list I
go back and do it until I have a pass
where I go all the way through the list
and I don't do any swaps and in that
case I know I'm done because
everything's in order and I can stop one
of the properties of it is that the
largest unsorted element is always at
the end after the pass in other words
after the first one I know that the
largest elements at the end after the
second one the largest thing left is
going to be in the next place and that
tells me among other things that this is
going to take no more than n times
through the list to succeed might
actually take fewer than that okay
gain let's look at some code for it
let's look at its complexity and let's
actually run this so here is a little
simple version of bubble sort I'm going
to set a flag up here I'm going to call
it swap initially to false that's going
to let me tell when I'm done when I'm
gone through everything in the list
without doing a swap and then I'm going
to loop as long as swap is false so the
first time through it's going to do that
loop I set swap initially to true and
notice what I then do I let J range from
1 up to the length of the list and I
look at the J element in the previous
element if the previous element is
bigger I'm going to flip them right
there and that's just doing that swap
what I just did down here and if that's
the case I'm going to set the flag to
false which says I've done at least one
bubble as part of this which means when
I come out of here and go back around to
the loop it's going to do it again and
it will do it until all of this succeeds
without this ever being true in which
case that's true which makes that false
and it will drop out ok let's look at an
example of this running it's just to
give you a sense of that assuming I can
find the right place here so there's a
gain aversion a bubble sort on the side
and I'm going to bring this down to the
bottom I've got a little
list there and I'm just I've put a print
statement in it so you can see each time
through the loop what's the form of the
list as it starts and assuming I've done
this right here you go
there's the list the first time through
notice after one pass twenty fives at
the end of the list the biggest element
exactly what I like but you can also see
a few other things have flipped right
right in there there have been some
other swaps as it bubbled through and in
fact you can see it's well you can see
that idea you can see 25 moving through
notice on the next step a whole bunch of
the list is actually in the right order
it's just because I got lucky
all I can guarantee is that the second
largest element is at the second and or
the second from the end at the list but
you can see here even though the list is
I think 9 long it only took us 4 passes
through so this is nice it says at most
n times through the list and at the end
we actually get out something that's in
the right form okay so let's go back to
this and basically say what's the
complexity
well that's length n right has to be I'm
going through the entire list and inside
of there is just constant work for
operations I'm doing a test that's right
5 I'm doing a test and in depending
whether that test is true or not I'm
setting a flag and doing some movement
of things around but it's just cost I
don't care about the 5 and there how
many times do I go around the loop in
the worst case in all I can guarantee is
after the first pass bigger thing is
here to the second pass the second
biggest thing is there after the third
pass you get the idea so I've got order
and things inside the loop and I'm doing
that loop n times and I hope that looks
familiar we've talked about this right
this is nested loops
what's this quadratic so it's order N
squared where n is the length of the
list now as you also saw on average it
could be less than that but it's going
to be order N squared ok
that's one possibility here's the second
nice simple sort algorithm it's called
selection sort and kind of think of this
as going the other way not completely
but going the other way when I say going
the other way the idea here is that I'm
going to find the smallest element in
the list and I'm going to stick it at
the front of the list when I'm done and
simply swap that place with whatever was
there flip them I might do a few other
flips along the way depending how I
implement this next pass I'm just going
to look at everything but the first
element because I know that one's done
I'm going to do the same thing find the
smallest element remaining in the list
put it in the second spot and keep doing
that what I know is if I implement this
correctly after I steps the first il
immense of the list will be sorted and
everything in the rest of the list has
to be bigger than the largest thing in
the first part of the list okay so we
could build that before we do it I'm
going to show you a little video
starring professor Guttag this is his
cameo perfect performance here but I
want to just show you an example of this
using not numbers but people all right
so now we're going to do selection sort
the idea here is that each step we're
going to select the shortest person and
put them next in line of the sorted
group so we'll bring the leftmost person
forward and we will compare her to
everybody else so one at a time step
forward you're still the winner you go
back please step forward
and while your different comparisons
that go on by the way we're going to
talk about
still the winner next ah a new winner
all right so you can take her place so
here we're choosing to actually insert
into the spot in the line we could have
put her back at the front but this is
not one where same old winner same
winner no change
let's keep getting kind of boring don't
fall over same winner please this is a
tough one oh close but I think you're
still shorter all right
next no change which means you are the
first in line congratulations
so smallest element now round down the
first step forward and we'll compare you
and I would invite you to watch the left
hand of the list notice how it is slowly
building up at each stage to have that
portion sorted and we deliberately admit
students to be of different heights so
gong-gong can do this demo you are the
winner take your place in line next
it's you
and once again we have a lovely group of
students sorted in height order and
check out I want you to remember number
of comparisons 55 not that the video but
I want you to see comparison as we go on
in a second so gain selection sort this
is this idea of find the smallest
element put it at the front and I might
do a little a number of flips as you can
see here along the way but this is the
same sort of animation of that so let's
first of all convince ourselves it will
do the right thing and then look at some
code and then run the code so to
convince ourselves that this is going to
do the right thing we could talk about
something that we often refer to as a
loop invariant we're going to write a
loop what we're going to walk through
this and the invariant here we want to
just demonstrate if it's true at the
beginning and it's true at each step
therefore by induction as we did earlier
I can conclude it's true always is that
if I'm given the prefix or the first
part of a list from 0 up to I and a
suffix or a second part of the list from
I plus 1 up to the end of the overall
list given that then I want to assert
that the invariant is that the prefix is
sorted and no element of the prefix is
larger than the smallest element of the
suffix just what I said early says at
any stage here if this is the amount of
sort I've done so far I can guarantee
I'm going to claim this will be sorted
and everything here is bigger than that
thing there how do I prove it well the
base case is really easy in the base
case the prefix is empty I don't have
anything so it's obviously sorted and
everything in the suffix is bigger than
anything in the prefix so I'm fine and
then I just want to say as long as I
write my code so that this step is true
that I'm going to move the smallest
element from the suffix the second part
of the list to the end of the prefix
since the prefix was sorted this is now
sorted and everything in the suffix is
still going to be bigger than everything
in the prefix and as a consequence by
induction this is going to give me
something that says it's always going to
be correct
so here's code that would do that
here I'm just going to set a little
thing called the start of suffix or
suffix start initially it's going to
point to the beginning of the list and
then I'm going to run a loop and as long
as I still have things to search in the
list that that pointer doesn't point to
the end of the list what am I going to
do I'm going to loop over everything
from that point to the end of the list
comparing it to the thing at that point
if it's less than I'm going to do a swap
because I wanted to move it up and you
can see by the time I get through this
loop I will have found the smallest
element in the remainder of the list and
I would have put it at that spot
whatever suffix start points to and when
I'm done all of that I just changed this
by one having found the smallest element
I've stuck at at spot zero I'll do the
same thing having found the next
smallest element I know it's at point
one and I'll just continue around one of
these you can see here is as opposed to
bubble sort this one is going to take n
times around the loop because I'm only
moving this pointer by one so it starts
at 0 and then 1 and then 2 all the way
up to n minus 1 you can also see in this
particular implementation well I'm
certainly ensuring that the smallest
element goes into that spot I may do a
few other flips along the way I'm going
to find something I think is a smallest
element put it there and put that
element here and then when I find
another smaller element I may do that
flip I could have implemented this where
I literally searched for the smallest
element and only move that doesn't make
any difference in terms of the
complexity alright what's the complexity
here already said this part I will loop
n times because I start at 0 and then 1
you get the idea inside of the loop I'm
going to walk down the remainder of the
list which is initially N and then n
minus 1 and then n minus 2 times but
we've seen that before as well while
they get shorter that complexity is
still quadratic
order n times going through this process
within the process order and things that
I have to compare and yes n gets smaller
but we know that that that that n term
if you like dominates so again this is
quadratic okay before you believe that
all sorting algorithms are quadratic I
want to show you the last one the one
that actually is one of the I think the
prettiest algorithms around in a great
example of a more efficient algorithm
it's called merge sort merge sort takes
an approach we've seen before talked
about dividing conquer break the problem
down into smaller versions of the same
problem and once you've got those
solutions bring the answer back together
for merge sort that's pretty easy it
says if I've got a list of 0 or 1
elements it's sorted da okay if I got a
list of more than one element here's my
trick I'm going to split it into two
lists I'm going to sort them and when
I'm done I'm just going to merge those
two lists into one list and the merge is
easy because if I've got two lists that
are sorted I just need to look at the
first element of each take the one
that's smaller add it to my result and
keep doing that until one of the lists
is empty and then just copy the
remainder of the other list you can
probably already get a sense of what the
cost is going to be here because this is
cutting the problem in half now I've got
two pieces so I need to think about both
of them I want to give you a couple of
visualizations of this here's the first
one it says basically I've got a big
unsorted list I'm going to split it and
I'm going to split it and I'm going to
split it until I get down to just lists
that are either 0 or 1 which by
definition are sorted and once I'm at
that level then I just have to merge
them into a sorted list and then merge
them pairwise into a sorted list and you
get the idea
so it's dividing conquer the divide is
dividing it up into smaller pieces the
conquer is merging them back together
and we have professor Guttag back for an
encore together with his students so
let's show you an example of merge sort
so we're about to demonstrate mergesort
and we're going to sort this rather
motley collection of MIT students by
height so the first thing we need to do
is we're going to ask everyone to split
into a group of two so you split a
little bit you two were together you two
are together you two are together you
two are together and you are all by
yourself
I'm sorry are guarana so now let's take
the first group take a step down and
what we do is we sort this group by
height with the shortest on the left and
look at this we don't have to do
anything thank you
feel free to go back up we then sort the
next pair please and it looks to me like
we need to switch all right take a step
back ladies
okay ladies gentlemen also okay
and again okay notice each side knee
you're now short order which is great
now what we do is we take these groups
and merge the groups so let's have these
two going to sort these groups have them
step forward and now what we're doing is
we're doing a merge of the two sorted
groups so we start by merging them we'll
take the leftmost person in this group
and compare her to the first person in
this group and decide she's still the
shortest take a step back now we're
going to look at you and say you're
actually taller than this fellow so you
now step up there and we're good here
both of you take a step back now we'll
take these two groups and follow the
same procedure we'll merge them let's
see we'll compare you the first person
in this group to the first person in
this group now it's a little tricky so
let's see the two of you compare let's
see back-to-back we have a winner
set back and now you need to compare the
shortest person in this group to the
shortest person in this group we have a
winner it's you I'm sorry
and now we just we're okay please step
back
now we'll have these two groups come
forward will compare the shortest person
in this group to the shortest person in
that group I actually need you guys to
get back to back here you are the winner
and it's pretty clear that the shortest
person in this group is shorter than the
shortest person in that group so you go
there and you step back
notice the groups and they all sort it
we repeat the same process and notice
how the whole subgroup now goes up once
we know that one group is empty and you
can see that we have a group of students
sorted in order by height remember the
first number right 55 28 now this is
just numbers but you can see the
expectation is this is going to take
less time and it certainly did there so
gain just the demo in another way
visually I'm sorting sorry I'm splitting
down until they got small things and
then just merging them up I may have to
do multiple passes through here but it's
going to be hopefully faster than the
other methods we looked at I'm going to
show you code in a second and then we're
going to run it just to see it but let
me stress one more time just the idea of
merging you can see the idea I keep
splitting down till I got something
small enough I want to merge them back
the idea of merging you've seen it from
Professor Guttag but I just want to
highlight why this is going to be
efficient if I've got two lists list one
and list two the things left their
process is very simple I pull out the
smallest element of each I compare them
and I simply put the smallest one into
the result move on in that first list so
the one disappears from that left list
and now again I pull out just the
smallest element of each one do the
comparison smallest one goes to the end
of my result and I drop that element
from its list so I've now taken one from
list one excuse me one from list two
and you get the idea the reason I want
to give you this visualization so let me
do the last step once I get to a place
where one of the lists is empty just
copy the rest of the list onto the end
you can see already a hint of the code
and that is that I'm only going to ever
look at each element of each sub list
once as I do the merge and that's a nice
property having had them sorted I don't
need to do lots of interior comparisons
I'm only comparing the ends of the list
I only therefore look at each element
the number of comparisons rather I
should say I do leave I may look at each
element more than what's the number of
comparisons is going to be at most the
number of elements in both lists and
that's going to be a nice queue as we
think about how to solve it so here's
the code to merge and then we'll write
merge sort and I know there's a lot of
code here but we can walk through it and
get a good sense of it I'm going to set
up variable called result that's going
to hold my answer and I'm going to set
up two indices I and J that are
initially 0 they're pointing to the
beginning and remember the input here is
two lists that we know are sorted or
should be sorted or we screwed up in
some way so initially I and J are both
pointing to the beginning of the left
and right lists and look at what we do
we say as long as there's still
something in the left list and still
something in the right list I is less
than the length of left J is less than
the length of right do the comparison if
the left one's smaller add it to the end
of result to the end of result right I'm
appending it because I want it to be in
that sorted order and increase I if it's
not add the right one to the end of
result and increase J and I'll just keep
doing that until I exhaust one of the
lists and when I do I can basically say
if the right list is empty I know if I
get out of here they can't both be true
in other words if there's still
something in the left list just put it
on the end otherwise if the only things
left on the right list just put them on
the end so I'm just walking down the
list doing the comparison adding the
smallest element to my result and when
I'm done I just return result
complexity we can already begin to see
here right this says the left and right
sub lists are order so I'm just moving
the indices depending on which one holds
the smaller element and when I get done
I'm just returning the rest of the list
so what's the complexity here I'm going
to do this a little more informally you
could actually do that kind of
relationship I did last time but what am
i doing I'm going through the two lists
but only one time through each of those
two lists
I'm only comparing the smallest elements
so as I already said this says that the
number of elements I copy will be
everything in the left list and
everything in the right list so that
order is just the length of left plus
the length of right and how many
comparisons do I do the most I have to
do is however many are in the longer
list right that's the maximum number I
need to have oh that's nice that says if
the lists are of order n I'm doing order
n copies because order n plus order n is
just 2 n which is order N and I'm doing
order and comparisons so it's linear in
the length of the list okay sounds good
that just does the merge how do I do
merge sort well we set it break the
problem in half keep doing it until I
get sorted lists and then grow them back
up so there's merge sort it says if the
list is either empty or of length one
just return a copy of the list it's
sorted otherwise find the middle point
there's that integer division and split
split the list everything up to the
middle point and do merge sort on that
split everything in the list from the
middle point on do more merge sort on
that and when I get back those two
sorted lists just merge them again I
hope you can see what the order of
growth should be here
cutting the problem down in half at each
step so the number of times I should
have to go through this should be log in
the size of the original list and you
can see why we call it divide and
conquer on dividing it down into small
pieces until I have a simple solution
and then I'm growing that solution back
up so there's the base case there's the
divide and there's the nice conquer
piece of this okay I'm going to show you
an example of that but let's actually
look at some code sorry about that let's
look at some code to do this and in fact
I meant to do this earlier and didn't I
also have a version of bubble sort here
sorry selection sort I've already done
bubble sort there selection sort let's
uncomment this and let's run both of
those and just see the comparison
between them and sorry just to make that
a little easier to read there we go so
we saw a bubble sort it only went
through four times so less than n times
their selection sort and as I said to
you it has to do and passes because it
can only ever guarantee that it gets one
element at the beginning so you can fact
see in this case from the first or after
the initial input until the end of the
first step it looks like it didn't do
anything because it determined
eventually that one was in the right
spot and similarly I think there's
another one right there where it doesn't
do any are peers not to do anything all
it's guaranteeing is that the next
smallest element is in the right spot as
we get to the end of it and in fact ends
up in the right place and then let's
look at merge sort and the one more
visualization of this so again let me
remove that and if we run it gene I've
just put some print statements in there
here you can see a nice behavior I start
off calling merge sort with that which
splits down into doing merge sort of
this portion eventually it's going to
come back down there and do the second
one it keeps doing it until it gets down
to simple this that it knows are sorted
and then it merges it does the smaller
pieces and then merges it and having now
to merge things it can do the next level
of merge so you can see that it gets
this nice reduction of problems until it
gets down to the smallest size so let's
just look at one more visualization of
that and then get the complexity so if I
start out with this list sorry about
that what I need to do is split it take
the first one
split it keep doing that until I get
down to a base case where I know what
those are
and I simply merge them pass it back up
take the second piece split it until I
get down to base cases do the merge
which is nice and linear pass that back
up having done those two pieces I do one
more merge and I do the same thing I
want you to see this because again you
can notice how many levels in this tree
log log in the sides because at each
stage here I went from a problem of
eight to two problems of for each of
those went to two problems of two and
each of those went to two problems of
size one all right so the last piece is
what's the complexity here's a simple
way to think about it at the top level
I've got I start off with n elements
I've got two sorted lists of size n over
two and to merge them together I need to
do order and work because as I said I've
got to do at least n comparisons where n
is the length of the list and then I got
to do n plus n copies which is just
order in so I'm doing order n work at
the second level it gets a little more
complicated now I've got problems of
size n over four but how many of them do
I have four oh that's nice because what
do I know about this I know that I have
to copy each element at least once so
not at least once I would copy each
element exactly once and I'll do
comparisons that are equal to the length
of the longer list so I've got four sub
lists of length n over four that says n
elements oh that's nice order n at each
step sub problems get smaller but I have
more of them but the total size of the
problem is n so the cost at each step is
order n how many times do I do it log in
so this is log in iterations with order
and work at each step and this is a
wonderful example of a log linear
algorithm it's n log n where n is the
length of the lift
so what you end up with then is I'll
write a joke version some reasonable
ways of doing sort that are quick and
easy to implement but are quadratic and
then an elegant way of doing the search
this end login and I'll remind you I
started by saying as long as I can make
the cost of sorting small enough I can
amortize that cost and if you go back
and look at last lectures notes you'll
see n log n grows pretty slowly and it's
actually a nice thing to do it makes it
reasonable to do this sort and then I
can do the search in order n time and
here's the last punchline it's the
fastest we can do I'm going to look at
John again I don't think anybody has
found a faster sort algorithm right this
is the best one can do unless you do
sorry the best worst case I've said John
is absolutely right there are better
average cases again our concern is worst
case so this is as good as we're going
to do in terms of a worst case algorithm
so there you now have sorting algorithms
and searching algorithms and you've now
seen excuse me sorry constant log linear
log linear quadratic and exponential
algorithms I remind you we want things
as high up in that hierarchy as possible
all right I have six minutes left some
of you are going to leave us we're going
to miss you but that's okay I'm sure
we'll see you later on for those of you
hanging around this isn't a bad time
just to step back and say so what have
we seen and I want to do this just very
quickly I'm sorry I remind you we
started by in some sense giving you a
little bit of a contract of things we
were going to show you and I would
simply suggest to you what have we done
we given you a sense of how to represent
knowledge with data structures tuples
lists dictionaries more complicated
structures we've shown you some good
computational metaphors iteration and
loops recursion as a great way of
breaking problems down into simpler
versions of the same problem and they
really are metaphors there are ways of
thinking about problems we've given you
abstraction the idea of capture
computation buried in a procedure you
now have a contract you don't need to
know what happens inside the procedure
as long as
delivers the answer it says it would or
another way of saying it you can
delegate it to somebody and trust that
you're going to get what you like out of
it we've seen classes and methods is a
wonderful way to modularize systems to
capture combinations of data and things
that operate on them in a nice elegant
way and we just spent a week and a half
talking about classes of algorithms and
their complexity if you step up a level
what we hope you've gotten out of this
are a couple of things you've begun to
learn computational modes of thinking
how do i tackle a problem divide and
conquer how do I think about recursion
is a tool in dealing with something
you've begun to begun I will use that
word deliberately to master the art of
computational problem solving how can
you take a problem and turn it into an
algorithm and especially you've begun to
have the ability to make the computer do
what you want it to to say if I've got a
problem from biology or chemistry or
math or physics or chemical engineering
or mechanical engineering how do I take
that problem and say here's how I would
design an algorithm to give me a
simulation and a way of evaluating what
it does and so what we hope we've done
is we started you down the path to being
able to think and act like a computer
scientist all right don't panic
that doesn't mean you stare at people's
shoes when you talk to them not all
computer scientists do that just faculty
sorry John so what a computer scientists
do and this is actually meant to be
serious and I put up two of my famous
historical figures of computer
scientists they do think computationally
they think about abstractions but
algorithms but automated execution so
the three A's of computational thinking
in the same way but traditionally you
had the 3 R's of reading writing
arithmetic
computational thinking we hope is
becoming a fundamental that every
well-educated person is going to need
and that says you think about the right
abstraction when you have a problem in
your Europe what's the right abstraction
how do I pull apart the pieces how do I
think about that in terms of the
decomposing things into a relationship
that I can use to solve problems how do
I automate how do i mechanize that
traction how do I use what I know
happens inside of the machine to write a
sequence of steps in a language I'm
using to capture that process and then
finally how do I turn that into an
algorithm and that not only means I need
a language for describing those
automated processes and a bill and if
you like allowing the abstraction of
details but frankly also a way to
communicate if you have to think crisply
about how do I describe an algorithm
it's actually giving you a way to
crystallize or clarify your thinking
about a problem this is not to say you
should talk to your friends in Python I
don't recommend it but it does say you
should use that thinking as a way of
capturing your ideas of what you're
going to do and that leads them to this
idea of how difficult is a problem how
best can I solve it we've shown you
these complexity classes and we've
hinted at the idea that in fact some
problems are inherently more difficult
than others that's something I hope you
come back to as you go along and
especially we want you to start thinking
recursively we want you to think about
how do I take a hard problem break it up
into simpler versions of the same
problem and then construct the solution
and that shows up lots of places right
recursion is in all sorts of wonderful
places so just to give you an example I
could say to you recursively this
lecture will end when I'm done talking
about this lecture which will end when
I'm done talking about this lecture
which will end when I'm done all right
you don't like infinite recursion good
luck on the exam
you